a groundbreaking sci-fi star a sitcom
scene stealer the first black movie star
these actors and more took their final
bows in 2022
Paul Sorvino worked in character roles
and on the New York stage throughout the
1960s and 1970s earning a Tony
nomination for his work in that
Championship season on Broadway in 1973.
Sorvino reprized his role as Phil Romano
in the 1982 film version of that
Championship season his mainstream
screen acting breakthrough in 1990
Sorvino would land back-to-back roles in
major movies which would amount to his
signature work gangster lips manless in
the big screen adaptation of Dick Tracy
and as the paternal calculating mob boss
Paulie Cicero in the crime Saga
Goodfellas in addition to criminals
Sorvino played a lot of authority
figures like Sergeant Phil surretta
early in the Run of Law and Order
Juliet's father in baslerman's Romeo and
Juliet and Henry Kissinger in Oliver
Stone's Nixon Sorvino died on July 25
2022 according to the actor's publicist
natural causes were to blame Sorvino was
83.
Nichelle Nichols had many roles in a
career that spanned more than 60 years
beginning with an appearance as a dancer
in the 1959 movie musical Porgy and Bess
of course she's best known for a
character she played on one of the most
influential and enduringly popular
Sci-Fi TV shows ever made from 1966 to
1969 Nichols portrayed Lieutenant nyota
Uhura on the original Star Trek
reprising the role in an animated Star
Trek series six movies and numerous
shorts and video games according to
variety nickels considered leaving Star
Trek after its first season for a stage
career but she was convinced to stay by
Martin Luther King who told the actor
that it was important for the Civil
Rights Movement for a black woman to be
on television in such a prominent role a
Sci-Fi icon Nichols worked extensively
over the decades and similarly
speculative shows including Futurama and
heroes Nichols business partner
confirmed the actor's death to Media
Outlets Nichols died on July 30 2022 in
Silver City New Mexico at the age of 89.
before she was an actor England born but
Australia raised Olivia Newton-John was
primarily known as a singer in the early
1970s her smooth and twangy sound made
her one of the few non-americans to find
success in country music she ascended
the pop and adult contemporary charts
too with hits like I honestly love you
and the movie business made good use of
Newton John's talents she starred as
Sandy in the Blockbuster film adaptation
of the Broadway musical Greece as well
as in the original movie musical Xanadu
with both films serving as major
vehicles for Newton John after scoring
the number one hit of 1982 with her song
physical Newton John focused more on
acting she reunited with her Greece
co-star John Travolta for the
supernatural rom-com Two of a Kind then
turned in various cameos in the 90s and
Beyond her most recent role was
co-starring as herself in the very
excellent Mr Dundee reflecting on the
Australian cultural craze she helped
start Newton John's husband John
easterling announced on Facebook that
the actor had died at home in southern
California on August 8 2022 A source
told TMZ that the cause of death was
breast cancer a disease with which
Newton John coped for three decades she
was 73.
after a long stint on the soap another
world and H made a big impression in the
Indie hit walking and talking and then
majorly broke out starring in Donnie
Brasco volcano I Know What You Did Last
Summer and wagged the dog all in 1997.
then H headlined the adventure comedy
Six Days Seven Nights and Gus Van sant's
psycho remake ultimately settling into a
career as a TV performer turning in
memorable arcs on shows like hung and
Chicago PD just to name a few H could
have probably been more famous and
prominent were it not for 90s era
anti-lgbt sentiment while competing on
Dancing With the Stars H revealed that
her three years plus romantic
partnership with Ellen DeGeneres lost
her work I got kicked out of my own
movie premiere because they didn't want
to get pictures of me with a woman in
early August 2022 H was driving
erratically through Venice Beach
California and crashed her car at a high
speed into a home H fell into a coma and
was in critical condition until August
11 when she was declared legally dead
over and insurmountable brain injury and
kept on life support only until her
organs could be donated H was 53.
Louise Fletcher's screen career reaches
back to the 1950s and encompasses more
than 130 roles but she's probably best
known for playing one of the most
memorable and terrifying movie villains
of all time nurse Ratchet In One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest this Landmark
film won five Academy Awards in 1976
including best actress for Fletcher she
also captured a Golden Globe and a bafta
for her performance Fletcher settled
into a wide variety of work after One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest including
Invaders from Mars and Flowers in the
Attic though few of these films hit the
heights of One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest Fletcher ended up finding
impressive success on the small screen
in the last few Decades of her life her
performance as villainous cult leader
kaiwan adami on Star Trek Deep Space
Nine and emmy-nominated turn as music
teacher Ava Garrison on Joan of Arcadia
were particular highlights Fletcher's
agent David Shaw reported to deadline
that the actor died in her sleep at her
home in France on September 23 2022 at
the age of 80 88
to put it simply Angela Lansbury was an
icon Lansbury was born in London and
made her first screen appearance at age
19 in the 1943 psychological drama
Gaslight I want to know whether it was
you who took the picture down call said
Walton sir what would I want to take it
down for the world soon took notice she
snagged Academy Award nominations for
that performance and the one she
delivered in The Picture of Dorian Gray
one year later Lansbury received another
Oscar nom for portraying a villainous
mother in the trippy political thriller
The Manchurian Candidate this is
arguably her most notable film work not
counting her turns in the Disney
Classics bed knobs and Broomsticks and
Beauty and the Beast concurrent with her
film and TV work Lansbury frequently
appeared on the stage starring in major
Broadway Productions like The King and I
Sweeney Todd and Mame she picked up six
Tony Awards along the way but Lansbury's
most unforgettable work arrived in 1984
when she began playing amateur sleuth
Jessica Fletcher on the smash hit TV
series Murder She Wrote This performance
earned Lane's very an astonishing 12
consecutive Emmy Award nominations well
my name is Jessica Fletcher I'm very
happy Jessica Fletcher the author
Jessica Fletcher well yes Lansbury died
in her sleep on October 11 2022 five
days before her 97th birthday
in the 1990s and Beyond Leslie Jordan
frequently appeared in short stints and
supporting roles on numerous TV comedies
almost always playing a heightened
scene-stealing version of himself a
sitcom Pro Jordan was a regular on the
cool kids and call me cat and injected
comedy into multiple installments of
Ryan Murphy's American Horror Story of
course he's probably best known for his
signature role that of socialite Beverly
Leslie both rival and friend to Karen
Walker on Will and Grace the very idea
makes me hell with mainly laughter
during the coronavirus pandemic
lockdowns Leslie became an online
sensation for his sweet silly and
revelatory Instagram videos which sent
his follower count into the
multi-millions according to TMZ Jordan
was driving through Hollywood on the
morning of October 24 2022 when he
experienced a sudden medical issue that
caused him to crash his car into a
building Jordan was pronounced dead at
the age of 67.
Kevin Conroy was a member of an ultra
exclusive Club one of a handful of
people to portray Batman on screen and
to many he was the best actor to ever
portray The Dark Knight seeing as how
his deep voiced understated and unique
take on the character would help create
a whole new line of Moody introspective
highly dramatic projects about Gotham's
tormented crime fighter
yeah
Batman Conroy first voiced Batman and
Bruce Wayne and Fox's acclaimed Batman
the Animated Series in the 1990s the
cartoon led to the big screen Batman
mask of the Phantasm and a slew of
direct-to-video projects Conroy would
further voice Batman in several related
Video game titles and even portrayed him
in a live action gig in a 2019 episode
of Batwoman Conroy had more than 100
credits to his name most of them voice
acting after launching his career in the
1980s according to variety Conroy died
on November 10 2022 shortly after
receiving a cancer diagnosis the actor
was 66.
Jason David Frank was a 90s icon
endearing himself to a generation of
fans as Tommy Oliver aka the Green
Ranger the character first appeared in
season one of Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers during the five-part episode
green with evil originally Tommy was a
bad guy Enchanted by Rita repulsa to do
her bidding and destroy the Power
Rangers but thanks to the Red Ranger
Tommy was eventually freed from his
curse and joined the teenage team of
martial arts heroes although his
rebellious nature often led him to clash
with his colleagues Frank's character
was one of the most popular in Power
Rangers history with Tommy eventually
donning the mythical suit of the White
Ranger outside of the flagship TV show
he would reprise the role of Tommy
Oliver in multiple films and Power
Rangers series in addition to his TV gig
Frank absolutely loved martial arts he
started training in karate at the age of
four and when he was older he had a
short but successful MMA career winning
three amateur fights and one
professional bout he also started his
own Dojo near Houston Texas which he
named Rising Sun karate tragically Jason
David Frank died by suicide on November
19 2022 at the age of 49. he is survived
by his four children
Kirsty alley died at the age of 71 in
December 2022 the cause of death was
cancer which as her children explained
in a statement had only been recently
discovered however Ali leaves behind
quite the impressive filmography she
starred alongside John Travolta in the
Look Who's Talking Series where they
played the parents of a baby whose inner
monologue sounds a lot like the voice of
Bruce Willis Star Trek fans remember her
fondly as Spock's Protege in 1982's
Wrath of Khan and 90s kids who loved
Mary Kate and Ashley Olsen movies will
definitely recall her from it takes two
she was the lead of her own sitcom NBC's
Veronica's Closet and if you're a fan of
reality TV Ali made her Mark there as
well dancing her way across the Masked
Singer and dancing with the stars of
course the role that Ali will be best
remembered for is Rebecca Howe in cheers
she joins the sitcom after the departure
of Shelley Long those were some big
shoes to fill and Ali did an incredible
job even winning an Emmy for her
performance in the show Cheers co-star
Ted Danson mourned her loss telling the
Los Angeles Times I am so sad and so
grateful for all the times she made me
laugh I send my love to her children as
they well know their mother had a heart
of gold I will miss her John Travolta
also mourned her passing posting on
Instagram Kirsty was one of the most
special relationships I've ever had I
love you Kirsty I know we will see each
other again I conic singer and actor
meatloaf who won a Grammy for his hit
ballad I'd do anything for love but I
won't do that and appeared in films like
The Rocky Horror Picture Show and Fight
Club died in January 2022. his manager
confirmed the news to the New York Times
but did not immediately reveal the cause
of death he was 74 born Marvin Lee a day
the Dallas native adopted his childhood
nickname as a stage name early in his
career he got his big break when he
auditioned for the Off-Broadway musical
more than you deserve in the early 70s
he won a role and formed a lifelong
partnership with writer Jim Steinman who
would go on to pen Meatloaf's debut
album 1977's Bat Out of Hell Todd
Rundgren produced the record and
everyone from the New York Philharmonic
to members of the E Street Band
contributed it was an unlikely hit that
critics begrudgingly praised though
meatloaf would struggle to replicate its
success in the years that followed after
a few flops he dropped 1993's Bat Out of
Hell 2 back into hell which included his
grammy-winning single in terms of films
meatloaf is best known for playing Eddie
the delivery boy in 1975's The Rocky
Horror Picture Show and former
bodybuilder Bob Paulson in 1999's Fight
Club other notable credits include
1992's Wayne's World 2001's the 51st
state and ghost Wars on which he
recurred between 2017 and 2018.
comedian and actor Bob Saget best known
for his long stint on the sitcom Full
House died in January 2022 in his hotel
room there was no evidence of drug use
or Foul Play according to chief medical
examiner Joshua Stephanie he was 65. his
wife Kelly Rizzo Saget said in a
statement per variety I am so completely
shattered and in disbelief Zagat made
his TV debut as Bob the comic in a 1981
episode of the Tom Hanks Sitcom Bosom
Buddies in 1987 he won the part of Danny
Tanner on Full House which became a
career defining role Zagat played the
widowed father of three from 1987 to
1995 and reprized the role in the
Netflix produced sequel series Fuller
house well just remember when children
seem the least lovable it means they
need love the most it was often hectic
on set but Saget had fond memories of
working with his on-screen kids the
actor told Vanity Fair in 2014 Jody
Sweden was four when she started Ashley
and Mary Kate were nine months Candace
was nine you're talking about
exceptionally talented young kids
elsewhere Saget was known as the voice
of the older Ted Mosby on How I Met Your
Mother and as the host of America's
Funniest Home Videos which he fronted
for almost a decade french actor Gaspard
juliel was best known to International
audiences for his turn as the young
Hannibal Lecter sadly he died due to a
skiing accident in January 2022 as
reported by deadline he was 37 yuliel
began his career on French television in
the late 1990s and was Landing film
roles by the early 2000s his big break
arrived in 2004 when he landed the part
of manek In A Very Long Engagement
juliel won his first Caesar award for
this movie and would make the transition
to Hollywood soon after playing the
titular killer in the 2007 prequel film
Hannibal Rising it was one of his
biggest roles at the time of his death
but the actor was also about to make his
debut as a Marvel villain sadly yuliel
died a few months before Marvel's Moon
Knight dropped he plays Anton mogar to
AKA Midnight Man a black market
Antiquities dealer who goes head to head
with the titular hero
Emmy winner Louis Anderson who appeared
in films like Ferris Bueller's Day Off
and coming to America died of
complications from cancer in January
2022 his publicist confirmed to CNN he
was 68 tributes from across the
entertainment World poured in after the
news broke screenwriter Carl curlander
wrote in a deadline tribute piece I was
one of the lucky ones who got to call
Louie a friend he made me and others in
his orbit feel like family Anderson
decided to give stand up a go after his
colleagues dared him to go on stage the
audience loved him and it wasn't long
before he was making his Mark in the
comedy World Anderson's talent and
career were multifaceted he was as
comfortable in front of a crowd as he
was fronting game shows indeed he would
become a fixture on American TV screens
as the host of Family Feud from 1999 to
2002. Anderson applied his trade on
shows like Grace Under Fire Touched by
an Angel Chicago Hope and scrubs but
some of his best work came in the
Twilight of his career Anderson was
nominated for Emmy's three years running
for his performance on the Zach
galifianakis-led FX comedy baskets
winning in 2016. real presents
unnecessary
Hollywood Legend Sydney Poitier widely
seen as the first black movie star died
in January 2022 at the age of 94. as
confirmed by the New York Times Barack
Obama said in a tweet through his
groundbreaking roles and singular Talent
Sidney Poitier epitomized dignity and
Grace revealing the power of movies to
bring us closer together Denzel
Washington said of him in an interview
with people he was a gentleman and
opened doors for all of us that had been
closed for years Poitier earned his
first credited film role Dr Luther
Brooks in 1950s no way out he actively
avoided demeaning roles and by the end
of the decade his persistence began
paying off he became the first black man
to be nominated for the Academy Award
for best actor in 1959 blue blowing
critics away with his turn as an escaped
prisoner in the defiant ones he missed
out on that occasion but would make
history a few years later when he became
the first black man to win that award
for his performance as a traveling
laborer in 1963's Lilies of the Field
how did Poitier feel about opening so
many doors for black actors and artists
everywhere he once told Oprah Winfrey
it's been an enormous responsibility and
I accepted it and I lived in a way that
showed how I respected that
responsibility I had to
up and coming actor Moses J Mosley was
found dead in Georgia in January 2022
his agent Tabitha minshu told The
Hollywood Reporter Moses was a very
talented person with a bright light
around him he will be missed deeply by
his friends family and fans always a
ball of happy energy around him the
cause of death was not immediately
revealed by authorities who launched an
investigation to determine the
circumstances he was 31 a native of
South Carolina mostly studied at Georgia
State University before settling down in
Atlanta according to the Hollywood
Reporter he worked as a model before
transitioning into acting Mosley's first
credited role was playing Michonne's pet
Walker Mike on The Walking Dead in 2012
he would appear on the hit AMC show half
a dozen times over the next few years
Mosley went on to play Tick-Tock on USA
Network's Queen of the South and Usher
on HBO's critically acclaimed Watchman
series and Kadeem on Irv Gotti's Tales
his most notable feature film was 2017's
attack of the Southern Fried zombies in
which he played Robbie Mosley had
several projects in various stages of
production when he was reported missing
by his family including Hank and
Cadillac respect
Academy Award winner William Hurt who
owned the 80s with hits like The Big
Chill and Gorky Park died in March 2022
the actor was 71 years old and as his
son will said in a statement via variety
he died peacefully among family of
natural causes although not initially
publicly confirmed we now know that hurt
died from complications of prostate
cancer he was first diagnosed in 2018.
hurt left behind a major cinematic
Legacy born in Washington DC hurt
studied theology at Tufts before finding
his passion in acting the actor made his
debut film performance with Altered
States a psychedelic trip that mixes
mushrooms religious imagery and body
horror he followed that up with these
sexy Noir flick body heat the film that
propelled him to stardom after that hurt
won a best actor Oscar for his portrayal
of gay prisoner Luis Molina in Kiss of
the Spider Woman it was just the first
of four times he'd be up for an Oscar
with the academy nominating his work for
children of Alessa God Broadcast News
and a History of Violence fans will also
recognize hurt from projects like the
village and AI artificial intelligence
of course the man also left his stamp on
the superhero genre by playing Thaddeus
Ross the MCU antagonist who pursued
Bruce Banner and Natasha Romanoff
Estelle Harris came to fame as an actor
well into adulthood most familiar to TV
audiences as Estelle Costanza the
combative shrill-voiced mother of George
Costanza on the mega popular 90s sitcom
Seinfeld oh I can't believe it Frank
come here Harris appeared in nearly 30
episodes of the series she also used
that distinctive angry voice in a number
of other projects post Seinfeld
including the Toy Story movies as Mrs
Potato Head Brother Bear teacher's pet
and Futurama but Harris was much more
than an argumentative uniquely voiced
maternal figure she had more than 100
acting credits to her name all of them
coming in her late 40s and Beyond Harris
started her acting career in Community
Theater regional theater and summerstock
before segwaying into TV with
appearances in commercials according to
CNN she once appeared in 25 nationally
broadcast ads in one year according to a
statement from Harris's son Glenn via
agent Michael eisenstadt Estelle Harris
died on April 2nd 2022 a cause of death
was not provided the actor was 93. never
a leading man and almost always a
supporting character in Broad comedies
and family movies Gilbert Gottfried
became a household name because of his
public and on-screen persona it's hard
not to forget that perpetually irate
squinting malcontent screaming his
thoughts in a shrill scratchy overblown
New York accent
you can't believe it I just don't
believe it after a major breakthrough as
a member of the cast of Saturday Night
Live in the early 1980s Gottfried became
a fixture in 80s and 90s movies off to
re-run cultural touchstones for kids and
teens who grew up in that era he played
Sydney Bernstein in Beverly Hills Cop 2
Mr Peabody in all three Problem Child
movies and voice Diago in Aladdin he
also voiced the Aflac duck in a
long-running series of insurance
commercials that's to say nothing of his
dozens of other appearances in TV shows
and movies making use of his purposely
annoying all-purpose characterization
Gottfried was also a relentlessly
performing stand-up comedian and a dark
and twisted one favored by other
Knockaround Comics as evidenced by his
appearances on comedy Central's series
of celebrity roasts on April 12 2022
Gottfried's Twitter account broke the
news that the actor and comedian had
died following an unspecified long
illness Gottfried was 67. Mike Haggerty
was among the most prolific and
recognizable character actors of the
last 40 years popping up in more than
100 movies and TV shows he usually
played a Gruff blue-collar Working Man
type with a big mustache and pronounced
chicagoan accent among hagerty's most
familiar roles there's Davey a cable TV
station employee in Wayne's World and
apartment building superintendent Mr
trigger on friends who becomes Joey's
ballroom dance partner he also played
best friend of the main character in the
original overboard an auto shop owner on
Lucky Louie and a main cast role on the
George Carlin show Hagerty recently
played a captain on multiple episodes of
Brooklyn Nine-Nine appeared on Shameless
and played farmer Ed Miller on somebody
somewhere on her Instagram page somebody
somewhere star Bridget Everett reported
that Hagerty had died on May 5th 2022 in
Los Angeles a cause of death was later
revealed to be a seizure as a result of
an adverse reaction to antibiotic
biotics he was 67 years old
one of the finest and most recognizable
actors of his era Ray Liotta alternated
between rugged leading man roles and
quirky character actor Parts usually
playing tough guys criminals and
intimidating figures as well as
frequently sending up his Public Image
as a man of simmering unhinged intensity
who you think you're talking to Leota
was a prolific actor appearing in more
than 100 movies and TV shows since the
1980s he broke out in a big way with
back-to-back roles as the ghost of
Shoeless Joe Jackson in 1989's Field of
Dreams and real-life Mafia Big Shot
Henry Hill in Goodfellas Martin
scorsese's classic crime epic that would
earn six Oscar nominations that film
solidified leota's specialty of playing
men just barely on one side of the law
or the other similar to his performances
in something wild Copland unlawful entry
narc Observe and Report shades of blues
and the many Saints of Newark according
to deadline Leota was in the Dominican
Republic in May 2022 filming the movie
Dangerous Waters when he died in his
sleep he was 67. in a career spanning
more than 200 roles back to the early
1970s Philip Baker Hall became a
quintessential character actor he's
probably best known to audiences as
Lieutenant Joe Buckman a library cop
tenaciously investigating Jerry Seinfeld
for a decades overdue book on the
comedian's titular show you'll also
likely recognize him as the intimidating
but secretly sweet neighbor Walt on
Modern Family Dr Morrison on Curb Your
Enthusiasm and hippo game show host Hank
hippopolis on BoJack Horseman writer
director Paul Thomas Anderson also cast
Hall in prominent roles in his first
three features Hard Eight Boogie Nights
and Magnolia according to Hall's
daughter via The Hollywood Reporter the
actor died at home in Glendale
California on June 12 2022. Hall was 90
years old
a chameleonic and frequently employed
character actor Joe turkle racked up a
whopping 142 screen credits over a
career that spanned from the late 1940s
to the 1990s of course he's most closely
associated with the films of Stanley
Kubrick who cast the actor in three
films turkle starred in The Killing and
Paths of Glory but he's most famous for
his appearance in The Shining where he
played the creepy ghost Hotel bartender
Lloyd turkle was virtually retired by
the 1980s when Ridley Scott hired him to
play replicant maker Dr Elden Tyrell in
the 1982 sci-fi classic Blade Runner
other than those major filmworks turkle
was a constant presence over Decades of
television with One-Shot rolls on dozens
of memorable shows including Miami Vice
Fantasy Island Kojak The Andy Griffith
Show Bonanza Ironside and combat
according to variety turkle died in a
Santa Monica California hospital on June
27 2022. he was 94. one of the best and
most definitive actors of his generation
James Khan starred in some of the most
highly regarded films of the latter half
of the 20th century usually playing
tough guys criminals intimidating dudes
Macho men and inscrutable Patriarchs
Khan paid his dues on 1960s TV dramas
like Naked City The Untouchables and
Wagon Train moving into different roles
in the early 1970s Khan starred as the
title character in the adaptation of
John updike's Rabbit Run and played
real-life football player Brian Piccolo
in the acclaimed made for TV tearjerker
Brian's Song hey
he found probably his most iconic role
ever as Sunny Corleone in The Godfather
for which he received an Oscar
nomination later in his career Khan
would land memorable starring roles in
Alien Nation misery honeymoon in Vegas
and elf and joined the frothy NBC drama
Las Vegas sadly on July 7 2022 Khan's
family announced on Twitter that the
actor died the previous evening he was
82. Tony serico found the role of his
life as Peter Paul galtieri AKA Polly
walnuts on HBO's universally acclaimed
modern-day Mafia Saga of The Sopranos an
explosive funny and loyal Lieutenant
demob boss Tony Soprano sirico provided
comic relief as Polly walnuts offering
up terse one-liners and amusing
mispronunciations what do you hear what
do you saying he played similar
characters in Goodfellas Bullets Over
Broadway and mighty Aphrodite in recent
years and after The Sopranos ended
sariko traded on his image and tendency
to be Typecast playing tough characters
on comedy shows like a gangster on
American Dad and a Gruff dog on Family
Guy sariko's manager confirmed to Media
Outlets that the actor died on Friday
July 8 2022. he was 79. actor Dale
critchlow who was best known for playing
Lyle The Farmer in the offbeat cult
classic Napoleon Dynamite died in
February 2022 as reported by deadline he
was 92 a native of Utah who moved to
Idaho in his 30s critchlow landed his
small but memorable role by pure chance
the film was shot on location in Idaho
where critchlow lived and worked as a
real farmer he needed help with his
animals one day so his wife reached out
to the mother of writer director Jared
Hess he told East Idaho news my wife
called Jared hess's mother and asked if
one of her boys was there he came over
and he had a friend with him I drove the
truck out into the pasture and the Sheep
came over they grabbed those bucks and
pushed them into the truck and then
later he came back and said I want you
to be in my movie critchlow became well
known in his hometown of Preston after
the film became a success and was always
happy to pose for pictures he went on to
feature in another comedy 2006's Church
ball which was considerably less
successful but Chris remained famous for
his turn in Napoleon Dynamite despite
not being overly keen on the film he
said in 2020
[Music]
he played
kind of dragged out but other
celebrities lost this year nehemia
persov Peter Robbins Liz Sheridan Robert
Morse Fred Ward Larry Storch Gregory
itson